okay so if the ending of peninsula has
been eating at your brains
or you're just one of the people that's
dying to know what happens in the story
then this is the video for you welcome
to the heavy spoiler show
i'm your host definition aka the guy
that always looks rotten
in this video we're breaking down
everything you need to know about the
train to percent sequel and its ending
of corpse there will be heavy spoilers
here so if you don't want anything
ruined about the movie then i recommend
that you turn off now
you know we have a dead occasion to bad
puns as well
so yeah they'll be loads of rubbish like
that too anyway with all out the way
thank you for clicking this now let's
get into our breakdown of peninsula
okay so peninsula picks up in the midst
of the zombie outbreak from the original
film in this movie
we discovered that the virus was
actually created in a bio factory in the
middle of south korea
this of course has many similarities to
current conspiracy theories
that center around the coronavirus and
though this movie wasn't made with a
pandemic in mind
throughout there becomes a lot of
similarities to what we've seen in the
world today
trying to besan detailed how people are
very much doomed to fail when they make
selfish decisions
and this movie too follows in the
footsteps of its predecessor
thematically in that we watch the events
play out through the eyes of passengers
on board a speeding train as they try to
escape the country
mirroring this the opening of peninsula
picks up with ship captain jungsuk
and his family as they try to escape
korea by sea
on the road they encounter a family of
three and though
he initially stops to help them after
believing that the father of the trio is
bitten
he quickly abandons them to their fate
this is an extremely selfish move
especially since he could have at least
helped the mother and her child
and this decision very much bears
consequences on june sucks journey
and also the ending of the film when
they reach their ride
an outbreak happens onboard the ship
which ends up infecting his nephew
the boy's mother aka his sister refuses
to abandon her child
and thus he ends up locking her in with
the rest of the infected
his brother-in-law chill min returns to
see his wife get torn apart
and it's a really agonizing way to start
the movie this of course
shows the two sides of humanity there
are those that will abandon the ones
that they love in order to survive
another minute
even though their lives will be worse
without them whereas there are others
that will stay no matter what
jung-suk definitely falls into the
former group and though he gets to live
longer than his sibling and a son
it's clear that his life becomes
miserable because of it
now from the off peninsula is laced with
english dialogue
and it's clearly being aimed towards a
western market as much as it is an asian
one
i did find these elements slightly
jarring at points
but on the whole i think they work
really well to play the best of both
worlds in the telling of the story
it does suck that these films kind of
have to pander to us because
we refuse to read subtitles and yeah at
least this will reach a lot more people
than the first movie
we predominantly learn the ins and outs
of the pandemic through american
voice-overs
and these detail a quarantine situation
that ended up happening in korea
the entire nation was cordoned off and
this is where the title comes from
korea itself is a peninsula and whereas
the first film took place on board a
train
this is upscale to use most of the
region for its setting
because it's a no-go zone refugees have
flooded into other areas
and we joined jung-suk four years later
in hong kong
jung suk has had a big fall from grace
and the ex-military man has now been
reduced to living in poverty
amongst a squalor neighborhood fraught
with criminals and gangsters
so naturally when he's offered the job
of retrieving 20 million dollars on
board a truck within the quarantine zone
he reluctantly accepts it since the
country was abandoned in the space of a
day
people have been trying their luck and
they've journeyed into the gold reserves
banks and institutions in order to loot
them
because korean currency is now pretty
worthless the fact that this loot
is in dollars will help them massively
and thus it becomes a more and more
attractive offer though i wouldn't be
caught
dead doing it uh the dislike buttons
right there now as we learned in the
first film
the undead are almost blind at night and
thus the job should be pretty
straightforward for him
chillman and two others however it turns
out to be
a grave mistake as when they arrive at
the truck
they inadvertently alert the zombies and
hoards swarm upon them
i love how there's this kind of ticking
time bomb in the group in the background
and they soon find themselves stuck on
the wrong side of the border
with humans hunting them too they're
ambushed with flares which attract the
undead
and jung-suk only manages to make it out
of there with help from junai
and her sister yujin he abandons
chillman to his fate
and this echoes how he abandoned his
sister to die on board the boat
chulmin has held a grudge over this and
jung suk must learn to be selfless
similar to those that helped him he was
definitely going to die without the help
of the two siblings
and his poor decision-making is hammered
home when he realizes that their mother
was one of the people that he refused to
help pick up at the beginning
this quick decision has pretty much
ruined the entire family's life
and thus they've been forced to live in
a hell hole because of his misguided
choice
now whilst it sucks for them as an
audience i loved seeing this group
and watching eugene distract the dead
with a remote control car
is a brilliant moment these aren't the
only people living amongst the wasteland
either
and on the other side of the coin are
unit 631
a militant group led by sergeant huang
they're very much dog-eat dog and this
juxtaposes the other survivors who
think about their group as a whole
rather than themselves
this mirrors our world in many ways and
in the midst of the global pandemic
we've sort of seen two sides to humanity
there are those that realize
that in order to stop the virus it will
take a united front against it
in which we all make sacrifices and
others that are willing to break the
rules for their own selfish gains
not to get too political but we have
seen that on the whole
people are willing to work together and
make sacrifices whereas there are some
that won't even give up the littlest
discomforts
for a couple of months in order to not
spread the disease
though unintentional i think these two
sides very much represent this
and we watch how some are thinking long
term and reaching out to entities like
the un
whilst others are happy to just
recklessly descend into chaos
as long as they're enjoying themselves
after picking up the truck they discover
chill min
and private kim comes across the cash
and their satellite phone
he plans to escape with his ally captain
ciao
who are both tired of living in the loop
and the monotony that the camp has
turned into
here humans are used in gladiatorial
arenas where they're forced to fight
against the undead
and i very much got flashes of escape
from new york in these scenes
i would say that on the whole the movie
takes influences from the aforementioned
film
mad max and dawn of the dead to paint
out the best and worst of society in a
really engaging way
however it's at this point that the
movie kind of lost me a bit and i
actually read a lot of reviews before
the film
that said it wasn't as good as the first
movie
up until this point i probably found it
on par however it does seem to shift too
far away from the main driving force of
the movie
which was the relationship between jun
suck and chill min
to a rather stagnant plot that we've
seen in other films
i also felt like the cities and
environments were the main selling point
of this movie
and being stuck in this one place did
drag the pacing down in my opinion
kim and xiao make a deal with the
gangsters that send in jun suk
whilst chilmin is forced to fend for his
life to me huang and sao are incredibly
interesting characters
but both get a bit short changed in the
end being relegated to people that
kind of get lost in the plot whilst
everything heats up i feel like these
characters probably should have been
combined into the same person to tell
a more streamlined narrative as in my
opinion they're both done a disservice
john suck tells the family about the
boat and is past of abandoning them
and min jung tells of how 30 cars passed
turn a family on the road
which i think influences his final
decision they decide to infiltrate the
631 hideout in order to get the truck
and escape the peninsula realizing that
chilmin is alive
jung suk ambushes the shopping mall in
which the majority of the forces are
located
and he attempts to break chilmin out
however chulmin is killed by huang
but jung suk is saved and he manages to
escape in the truck alongside the other
members of the family
who some which ride in a jeep as the 631
try and hunt them down
this leads to a giant chase scene with
the undead running after the vehicles
which the militia do too it definitely
feels like the most heart pounding
moment of the movie
and i love the use of light and the way
that the vehicles turn into battering
rams just to pile through the wave of
zombies
it's an incredible action scene and out
of the two films
probably the tensest point between it
and its sequel they pass a location that
jung suk encountered earlier in the
movie
in which the undead were trapped behind
giant walls of glass
jung suk shoots this which frees them
and they swarm the convoy
killing huang and his forces which
allows the heroes to escape
upon arriving at the port xiao rams the
jeep
and takes junai hostage but eugene
manages to distract him with a car
he shoots the grandfather of the group
and manages to escape with the truck
upon arriving on board the boat he's
then betrayed by the gangsters
but in his last breath he reverses the
truck out the back which damages the
exit ramp
and opens it up to zombies who fled the
transport and kill all those on board
back with jung's sucking co the
grandfather unfortunately passes away
however the un helicopter that he
reached out to arrives
and jung suk junai and yujin clear a
path to the transport
realizing that they're going to get
swamped minjun locks herself into a
truck
and tries to distract the undead so that
the family can make their escape
now it's at this point that jung suk has
a choice he can either
leave her to his fate like how he was
willing to in the opening of the movie
or he can actually risk us like to say a
decision
that he should have made the first time
round he of course chooses the latter
and this shows that though he often
makes self-centered decisions
we still have the option to make things
right with the words of chulmin
echoing through his mind he realizes
that he was in a similar situation with
his sister
in which he allowed her to die when he
could have saved her but didn't because
of fear
this is hammered home by him telling the
family that their uncle will save their
mother
which in some ways rights the wrongs of
his past mistakes
and the sister and nephew that he left
to their own fate though it's often seen
for the greater good to let some people
make sacrifices
it's also a selfish decision on our
behalf because
we don't do our all and try our best due
to the fact that we think that they can
take the bullet for us instead
this is a message that's needed now more
than ever and as people
we have to realize that all life is
precious we must try and protect it at
all costs
and it's great to see jung suk actually
save her the four
escape on the un craft and one of the
staff on board says that
soon they'll be in a new world however
junior retorts this by saying
the world she knew wasn't bad either and
to me this
shows that even in the hell she lived in
because she had a family
she was still able to see the good in
life this juxtaposes jon suk
who made a selfish decision that cost
him his family and now he managed to
make it to this new world
he ultimately had nothing because he
gave up on the things that mattered to
him the most
it's a brilliant message that shows that
as long as we have each other
we have something and though it is
possible to live without one another
in the end we are what truly matters
because of his decision at the end
jung suk has managed to save her family
from going to what he did in the new
world
and he's truly made right on the wrongs
of his past the full fly-off into the
sunset
safe as a newly formed family and ready
to live their lives as one
together now before we get into the
review
i just want to let you know we're giving
away a free copy of the mcu infinity
soccer box set to one random subscriber
all you have to do to begin with the
chance of winning is like the video
subscribe to the channel and leave your
thoughts on the film in the comments
section below
the win is going to be chosen at random
on the 15th of august and the set will
be shipped out from then to ever gets
the prize
so best of luck to everyone who takes
part
okay so what did i think of the film
overall well i have to say that i really
enjoyed it
though i don't feel like it quite lived
up to the first entry
that's not to say it's bad i just feel
like the first film
captured my imagination in a way due to
its unique setting and overall themes
again this isn't a bad movie by any
stretch of the imagination
and it might even be unfair to compare
the two saying as they're both so
different from one another
i will say though that if you loved the
first movie and zombie films in general
that you will definitely have a blast
here and outside of its slower second
act the movie is a brilliant right from
start to finish
i really hope that this film isn't
delayed in its release to other parts of
the world
as it's definitely worth checking out
and recommend that you try and see it as
soon as you can
peninsula was great and i really hope we
get another film in the franchise
sooner rather than later overall this
was brilliant
and it gets an 8 out of 10. now
obviously i'd love to hear your thoughts
on it so comment below and let me know
if you enjoyed this video then please
give it a thumbs up and if you want
something else to watch then make sure
you check out our breakdown of the old
god which is going to be linked at the
end
if you want to support the channel and
get to see content early then please
consider clicking the join button below
you can also come chat to us on our
discord server or at heavyspoilers on
twitter
thanks for making it until the end of
the video you've been the best
i've been definition and i'll see you
next time take care
peace
[Music]
you